several months ago you see this tweet
that I'm highlighting here by
experimental philosophy about a change
in a graduate philosophy program and
this kicked off a lot of discussion in
philosophy Twitter that I've been
wanting to go back to for a while
because I think this conversation is
quite valuable and there's a lot that
people might be able to learn from
looking at what people had to say and
their responses to each other so let's
let's just look at the quote right off
the bat Yale philosophy has officially
replaced the grad program logic
requirement with a broader formal
methods requirement students can choose
which course to take logic probability
stats Game Theory Etc feels like a
symptom of a much larger change in the
discipline and there's a lot to be said
here is this indeed a much longer larger
change in the discipline it doesn't
matter that it's Yale what is a logic
class supposed to do for you in graduate
school these are all important issues
that will get into shortly but I think
it's very important first to add a
little bit of perspective that might be
missing to a lot of people so if we look
at this one we see Christopher Zorn
saying I don't know enough about
philosophy at one small school in the
Northeast to say whether this is good in
context but the general idea of
broadening disciplinary requirements at
The Graduate level strikes me as
generally positive thing and then here's
another
perspective adding a set of Reflections
by Hobbs Goblin my super hot take is
that unless you're a graduate student at
Yale or a prospective graduate student
at Yale Yale's changed their logic
requirement is actually not very
interesting why USC changed a similar
requirement like 16 years ago but I who
was a grad student there at the time
could not remember whether it was the
logic or language requirement that got
switched to research methods and this
brings up a very important Point people
get worked up about oh an Ivy League
school is changing something that
affects almost nobody and this is in a
philosophy program which yes there are
quite a few graduate students in it and
others will go through it but in the
grand scheme of things one school
changing a few things in this way
doesn't really affect the rest of us
even if we are in graduate school
elsewhere definitely not the case for me
and then we get some good reasonable
takes as well that I think are worth
looking at
Kevin zollman I think this is broadly a
good development I like logic and I
think it's great for people to take it
but met for many philosophers that
they're going to take one mathematical
or formal class logic is far from the
best one here's that's doctor I don't
think this is such a bad thing some are
making it out to be basic logic is a
required skill in philosophy but for
most people the more advanced formal
stuff isn't that helpful better to give
them formal training in areas that might
be more relevant to their areas
Elizabeth pickudo says I wasn't a
philosophy major so I was behind the
other grad students initially a policy
of read something when you actually need
to know it for what you're doing served
me well but I'm really glad I took the
formal logic that was required
um Ryan Muldoon says I forget if we've
done this officially or not but we've
been moving to this approach as well
students should get trained in the
formal methods that make the most sense
for their work chemtrup says seems like
a really positive change it push
students a bit to study formal areas
that might be more relevant to their
work than formal Logic for example a
metaphysics student studying theoretical
physics social political philosophy
students studying stats to understand
empirical matters then Brian Robertson
welcome news learning logic was great
but having to teach myself stats sucked
and so he's referencing there the fact
that the kind of work that he did entail
learning proven stats probability and
statistics and instead of being able to
do that in the department he basically
had to do that on his own so those are
all some good takes I'd say and then we
got this interesting
sub conversation Florence who often says
quite controversial things on Twitter
says this is so sad it's honestly a
really worrying Trend happening right
now that philosophy phds keep lowering
the bar on their requirements and you
know I actually will fess up to the fact
that you know if you'd looked at me 30
years ago I probably would be saying the
same stuff as Florence is here and so
Florence says if anything things should
be more difficult in this respect the
people who don't need such a requirement
will find it easy it's if it's difficult
that's all the more reason one needs to
do it it's sort of like the sink or swim
or we all have to be tough in philosophy
and then Caleb Ward said
seems like formal methods are formal
learning a different formal method isn't
necessarily lowering the bar right or
maybe this was sarcasm in which case
please ignore it and then Florence
responds you're definitely right that
for this reason this change is way less
objectionable than a lot of requirements
that have been dropped or made more
lacks but I do worry that a lot of
formal methods classes such as
statistics which is mentioned don't
train for the same skills and now that
is a reasonable worry but as it turns
out maybe some of the same skills are
being fostered we'll see that discussed
later on then we get a very interesting
close to this Sarah says this has
already been said but I don't really
think this involves any lowering of bars
it's just a way of ensuring that this
particular bar continues to assess the
relevant kinds of formal training and
then Florence says yes I do now worry
I've projected some general feelings
onto a particular case and and Sarah
says surely would any true philosopher
would do and so this is a kind of good
to observe isn't it a philosopher saying
you know I might have overreacted to
this I'll have to think about it more
uh then we have a great clarificatory
conversation that was spurred by Harvey
Letterman who says I'm in favor of
having a single course that all grads
take which covers basic topics from all
relevant formal areas probability modal
logic semantics decision Theory the old
model of a strict logic requirement is
not relevant to most research but I
think we benefit as a profession from
having a shared language everyone can be
expected to know the free-for-all go
learn whatever methods you need model
does not achieve this there should also
independently be more scaffolding and
rewards for students to get intermediate
training in the formal areas most
relevant to them for example machine
learning or psychology a shared set of
tools as given by a basic class are part
of what makes the discipline coherent I
think that's a real value though what is
covered in the basic class should be
updated regularly so this would be a
pretty radical uh reworking of things
and Matt teigman I think this comment is
entirely on point this kind of feels
like the philosophy version of discrete
math which is often the only pure math
class A CS student computer science is
required to take and which represents
quite the smorgasbord of topics now if
you don't know what a smorgasbord is
it's a buffet and there's lots and lots
of stuff laid out you just grab whatever
it is that you want this is entirely
correct I can say as somebody who took
discrete math as a mathematics major it
is just a bunch of stuff kind of thrown
together and it's a really fun class but
it's not giving you any sort of like
coherent introduction to all of these
very interesting topics and it tends to
be one week we're doing this the next
week we're doing this
so
um continuing on with this there's a
discussion between Brad scowl and Harvey
Letterman
Scout says the rationale for a logic
requirement is that all philosophers
will at some point have to evaluate an
argument that doesn't extend a decision
Theory probability Etc requirement those
are irrelevant to many parts of
philosophy Harvey Letterman says well
that would motivate a propositional
logic class but most of the actual
implementations of a logic requirement
go into meta Theory and incompleteness
much fancier than what's used in actual
philosophy are you thinking modal and
conditional logic is generally needed as
well in any case I think probability is
extremely widely used these days in lots
of areas so I'm not sure it's restricted
as this comment suggested and then Brad
scowl says I think there's large parts
of value Theory where one could make
great contributions with no knowledge of
probability theory true but largely
irrelevant and Harvey Letterman says
sure but I think there's large parts of
philosophy where one could make great
contributions with no knowledge other
than modus ponens and modus tollens
still well we teach more than that so a
lot to think about with this
conversation about the pedagogy that
we're providing in graduate programs in
logic then we see some important
concerns expressed over gatekeeping and
this indeed is a real issue cam says I
don't have an opinion about curriculum
at Uni's I think shouldn't exist like
Yale but I'm seeing people celebrate
this because logic requirements get gate
kept good philosophers from getting
degrees and that seems odd to me it's a
style of thinking that's hard not logic
these specific subject
we also see uh Christina Easton saying I
knew someone during my PhD who
eventually got kicked off as they kept
failing the logic requirement I think
the general consensus was that he was a
good philosopher and then experimental
philosophy the original poster says well
that's horrible as a discipline we need
to racket we need to do more to
recognize there are different ways of
being a good philosopher and that not
all philosophers will look the same
ghostly phenomenology says the
requirements are almost always
unnecessary barriers though they don't
demonstrate any aptitude or anything
something like a logic requirement for
many philosophers will in no way help
them to do their work it's not lowering
the bar but recognizing it was a bad bar
very important distinction being
articulated there then we get sort of an
add-on this is a fantastic idea now do
it for languages there are very often
language requirements for philosophy
graduate programs and then experimental
philosophy says something that I mean
basically is happening in many places
you mean that instead of everyone taking
the same languages German ancient Greek
we should try to open things up so that
there are more people studying classical
Chinese or Arabic like for instance they
do at Marquette University for Arabic
because of the Aquinas and the Arabs
project anyway moving on there are some
worries about teaching philosophy the
logic requirement is supposed to prepare
you for being a good teacher Wesley
Buckwalter says I support the plurality
but here's one downside when students
get jobs teaching philosophy logic is of
course they are incredibly likely to
have to teach it just makes sense as job
training and then experimental
philosophy responds yes it's very
helpful in a number of respects to know
the kind of logic that's typically
covered in undergrad courses again an
important distinction but a graduate
course in logic typically covers other
stuff like first order meta Theory
completeness compactness lewinheim
scholm and I would actually interject
here that it's not the case that you
know logic is a course that you are
incredibly likely to have to teach I
would say ethics is actually much more
likely or if there's going to be a logic
class it's probably more likely these
days you're going to be teaching some
logic in a critical thinking or informal
logic class rather than the stuff that
you're doing in a graduate level logic
class Peter Joseph says
as teaching philosophy enjoying
philosophy and being a philosopher all
different things I doubt that
universities can know what exactly is
needed to know in philosophy as a
philosophy student who hated symbolic
logic I would have never submitted to
that requirement and this is in the
first part entirely dead on these
graduate programs typically don't know
very much about exactly what sort of
situations their graduates are going to
be in or what the let alone what's going
to be you know part of the curriculum 10
years from now or anything like that
they're they're kind of engaging in
enlightened guesswork
then we get some silly takes some not
quite so well thought out takes the
Athenian stranger who is an alt-right
account chances are can ultimately be
traced to its decision made according to
diversity Equity initiatives 100 you
know this is kind of dogmatic assertion
and uh experimental philosophy says yeah
that's not the case Uh Kevin Karem
philosophy requires that one love wisdom
you can't love wisdom if everything is
just a socially constructed tool no
relationship with something other than
yourself No Love No Love No philosophy
it's kind of hard to figure out what
point he's making there it seems more of
a rant than an on-topic contribution but
I you know I just wanted to give you
that and here's another one that's
equally so this is from Eric purchase
it's a sign that philosophy is melting
into the technocracy
now that one I don't get uh you know the
removal of the logic requirement or the
shifting it to Robin's stats is
philosophy melting into technocracy yeah
yeah I don't get it I mean this seems
more like somebody just throwing around
words
objectively correct I think coming uh
likely from left says can't believe the
ruling class institution is continuing
its quest to Bar rationality till the
teleology and logic from being accessed
by the filthy masses luckily millions of
warehouse workers and Petty weed dealers
are reading Hegel And discussing on
secret means tested social media well I
mean I can tell you that discussing
Hegel is not a substitute for formal
logic and that I would guess that most
of the people out there discussing Hegel
don't actually understand Hegel that
well so I'm not sure what that's got to
do with anything finally sock uh Sakura
Camis good that class is useless turning
what is mostly obvious into something
not obvious as well and not useful for
anything people don't reason that way
and reason is a slave to our biases
anyhow and you know you read stuff like
that and you're like well okay you
mighty had a point but you kind of
wrecked it on the way and how you were
articulating it and so these are all
I'll just say silly takes right they
they don't have much of a solid basis
then we have another set of takes that
kind of get logic wrong what is the
function of logic how does it work how
is it connected to other things so Pac
delary says proficiency and formal logic
should be a requirement for every degree
as it was in medieval universities and
you could say well
you know
um that's not quite the case and why the
hell would we want to model what we're
doing after medieval universities unless
we're hankerers after some ideal
Medieval Age right annoyed cat says that
will provide literacy problems for grad
students without logic much of
philosophy will not be comprehensible
that is totally wrong I mean you don't
need formal logic to make sense out of
most philosophy that you're going to
read I mean if that was indeed the case
then you couldn't have read Plato back
in the day because there wasn't formal
logic classes right uh Lauria Casserly
this is like stripping the solid math
space from physics and slipping in some
trashy watered-down well no it's
not that good of an analogy there
philosophy is not physics this is not
removing mathematics or anything quite
so Advanced and then we get a you know
this uh mastita gringa saying something
about letting philosophers get away with
stats is their formal method seems very
counter to the discipline of philosophy
and this strikes me as something that
somebody who hasn't really taken a
rigorous stats class would say I I mean
I've taken formal logic I used to
specialize in that I also did a lot of
work in probability and statistics and I
can tell you that it can get pretty
complex and rigorous finally a quack
quack
basically statistics are built off logic
so one is more foundational than the
other and philosophy seems to be a field
that should care about foundations also
most stats classes are garbage and do
little more than teach P values you've
got to say well where are you getting
this from uh are you an expert that has
like surveyed stat classes across the
more than 2 000 universities and
colleges we have here in the United
States or you're just blathering so Adam
leads weighs in I'm not familiar with
the logistis reduction of Statistics can
you give me a reference and here's
here's an example of a terrible argument
right quack quack statistics comes from
math math comes from logic you might as
well say well I guess you don't
understand any of that So Adam Leeds
says well you might find it interesting
to learn about the failure of the log
assist research program in the early
20th century which is quite relevant and
Quack Quack says I'm familiar math is
still based on logic even if the axioms
themselves can't be proven and must be
found in some other way and if you
actually know uh mathematics you know
the various things that fall into that
discipline if you worked in that field
and you know logic you know that yes in
some sense mathematics could be said to
be based on logic but you sure as hell
don't need logic or a graduate level
logic class in order to do mathematics
so you know once again some bad takes
and here's some sort of remedies to that
so the these are some good points about
logic and other disciplines Mary Beth
Willard says I suspect this is probably
fine it was always a little suspicious
that everyone needed first order meta
Theory I can't imagine a philosopher
versed in Game Theory isn't going to be
competent in logic anyway and then Diego
uh gorini says I struggle to see how one
can study either probability or Game
Theory without a basic understanding of
logic the principles of formal problem
solving are logical by contradiction
um and then rod and Crawley says I don't
know about Etc is that a term religion
would use but probability stats Game
Theory all would lead to an examination
of logic eventually if it wasn't
necessary before studying them so you're
kind you know if you put these together
I interpret this as saying listen you're
gonna get your logic Style along the way
you don't actually need a class just
specifically on that if you're studying
these other disciplines you're going to
get into it and then continuing on with
this
like before Tebow and I agree with with
this as a math guy I've always thought
probability would be more useful for
philosophy Majors than classical logic
um I definitely agree with that
especially in a culture in which
enumeracy is such a major problem David
Kinney says in my opinion a good stats
are probability classes of Greater
benefit to someone hoping to do research
in for example epistemology then would
be modal logic or set theory but I think
a good stance or probability class
should start with some set theory you
need to know what an algebra is quite
true and you're going to get that if you
take a good stats or probability class
most likely right
or you'll get it in the prereqs Elder
says this is very interesting and much
needed in my opinion I started expanding
the notion of formal methods in my own
teaching of critical thinking glad to
see that others are doing the same and
if you actually look at what critical
thinking classes look like or you look
at the various models of critical
thinking out there that have been
articulated for you know about three
decades or so going back
you'll see that other methods are
involved in that right Richard Lucas
says game theory is a worthy addition to
any philosopher's bag of tricks
uh the logic I see discussed in various
philosophy essays falls short of the
intellectual impact I see coming from
prob stats in a special Game Theory
applied in other Humanities Mitch
hirschbach says my grad program requires
two logic classes that covered
propositional logic and predicate logic
and modal logic I'd have been much
better served replacing modal logic with
probe and stats and frankly as somebody
who knows these I would I would tend to
agree uh modal logic is very fun and
cool and useful for some things but a
problem stats is just you know very
helpful finally Casey says is someone
who took Advanced logic in undergrad and
is now currently fulfilling my PhD logic
requirement a game theory or probability
course would have probably been more
useful at this point so I don't know why
people are mad at Yale for allowing this
seems good to me so we're getting you
know some good weigh-ins from people who
are stakeholders in this
um another thing that we need to think
about is
this aura that we surround logic classes
with we pretend or you know tell
ourselves that oh this is going to like
inculcate a certain mode of thinking but
we don't really know that now do we so
prosco says just randomly assign
students to take logic or one of the
other courses and then measure outcomes
years later an experimental philosophy
responds if we decide this is the best
method for answering our question it
feel almost feels like we thereby have
already before us an answer to the
question we are asking so you know this
would actually be a good experiment to
do very difficult to pull off of course
Goro shimura says one thing I'll say
about this is I think I'd be more
convinced by the people who insist that
everyone should learn first order meta
theory in particular if there were
evidence that the people who basically
have to be made to do so at gunpoint
actually retain any value from it
very important point there Arps tree
says I think if you study which logic or
Math More generally
the limitations of the discipline become
obvious especially in application to
more nebulous things like philosophy so
true
um you know it's it's always funny to
see the logic Bros and I saw this a lot
when I was in graduate school take
philosophical arguments shoehorn them
into some logical notation totally screw
them up in the process and then play
around with them and regurgitate
something that doesn't look remotely
like the argument that they started with
finally TL says I have no strong opinion
on the matter of this debate but there
is so much misunderstanding of what
logic is about in this discussion so the
required logic courses aren't that
successful whatsoever you know
presumably all the people who are
weighing in about how important logic is
and how we can't leave it out you know
should be demonstrating the positive
effects of having taken logic classes
otherwise they don't know what the hell
they're talking about and they're not
qualified to weigh in and unfortunately
they're saying bone-headed things some
of them
here's a joke that I thought we have to
put in here from Yuval genbar fine about
the proposal as long as it works in all
possible world so we're talking about
the possible World semantics that became
quite popular really from about the
1990s onward in analytic philosophy
which is all and also something that
people should probably learn in a
methods class perhaps then finally
experimental philosophy the original
poster says something that I think is
quite positive
in all the discourse about it one thing
I find really striking is the folks who
actually work in logic themselves keep
speaking out against the idea that logic
should be required this shows a truly
admirable openness and lack of
imperialism
so that's a good discussion that I
realize I'm you know we're coming a
little bit late to the game but you know
it's a sort of perennial topic and it
doesn't just concern Yale if it did then
I don't think most of us would care
about it unless we take Yale as somehow
being representative of philosophy which
it definitely isn't but this is a great
thing to think about how do we train
people in the discipline of philosophy
and we could extend this to other
disciplines as well what's important
stuff what are the skills what is the
content what are the uh capacities the
mindsets that we need to be promoting
and inculcating in graduate school and
do we have to do it one single way so
that's it for this one and we'll pick up
with plenty of other Twitter
conversations happening about philosophy
and related matters somewhere else down
the line